hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
now this might be the final episode of
this game everything seems to be on fire
and that's probably a problem but we
might be going back to an area that
we've already been to before which means
that we're gonna be backtracking over
places that were not on fire and now
we're on fire now I'm thinking of those
those fires armies that were spinning in
a circle may have had something to do
with all this but anyway hello everybody
my name is markiplier hello hello hello
yadda yadda yadda let's get going we
don't have coffee I just remembered
damn it's dammit toto
dammit toto did I talk to Hoffman about
all this I think I talked to Hoffman do
more things with my mind every time I
see him he uses my own nightmares
against me that sounds like him he's a
master of neuro linguistic programming
and in here the linguistic part becomes
irrelevant why talk when you can get
strained to your mind he almost had me
but I searched inside myself and there
was someone there someone who told me
what I needed to do I know I can take
him on now yes I can see that you're
ready how did you we're all friends
we're all friends here she didn't try to
save me don't feel guilty we talked
while I try to save her she told me
about the plan she wanted it to succeed
she made a decision to get you she knew
the risks and did what she thought was
right she said that she owed you
for what very quiet game volume just mad
Esmeralda is the operative who took Lily
from your home oh wait I know what's
going on I know I think I know hang on
one second let me
doodlee do
ah how about ah there we go
burned it down that better she's felt
better ever since that's why she joined
Myra that's why she risked her life I
was wondering why that was it was quite
for me too but I thought it was just on
my own Bastion
she didn't have a choice at the time and
she did everything she could to make it
right okay cool I can't hate her she
sacrificed herself with a plan she made
her immense all right
so thankfully they were uh they were
caught they were watching mccollins
subtitles there were subtitles clearly
where were the subtitles you know starts
with a Q sounds like subtitles okay here
we go there were subtitles that you
could read all that very important stuff
so
Theodore's an [ __ ] Esmerelda's a hero
or Toto rather and now I got a new gun
okay alright
oh no I feel bad though no I feel okay
I'm gonna put this at five and I'm gonna
put the sniper rifle at seven so I don't
accidentally use it because I have a bad
habit of doing that oh well I guess I
could just hit the middle mouse button
and mouse over it's not really like it's
that hard but I don't even know if I
have any oh I do look at this thirty
bullets that are gonna go to nothing cuz
I know this gun is worthless it's
goddamn worthless but also I need to get
back into the mirror because I need to
talk to the nurse about all this because
the nurse would probably have something
to say and I think I got one more slide
as opposed to everything else so maybe
and there's only two slides left in the
world and I'm hoping that there in this
next area because I want to find him I
want to find all of them yeah I just saw
that's just saw comma those bird
mentality
yes fashion what are you thinking about
Lily
everything that's happening in here is
because of her
everyone wants her like she's just some
object to be owned mmm she's the real
victim here poor thing doesn't know what
it's like to live a normal life all
these years with Moebius have probably
destroyed her innocence hmm I hope so
her youth was stolen from her she didn't
get a chance to go to school to have
friends all the birthdays and holidays
she missed it's heartbreaking to think
of what she's been through
Lily was always so precocious so smart
observant
she had this way of looking at you or
you knew that she understood you not
just what you were saying but what you
were feeling too I always knew she was
special
but I thought it was just because she
was my daughter I keep referring to her
in the past tense it still doesn't seem
real to me that she's alive and in here
[Music]
I still think Kidman I don't think
Kidman look suspiciously suspiciously
like someone we know now let me see if I
I'm gonna be scouring for this last two
slides so I'm gonna be looking all over
the place and I'm gonna miss it probably
very obviously oh thank you for the
group thank you yeah well okay let me
see what I got here boink do do do do do
do do do do
all right come on come on come on nurse
nurse we've got a problem
nurse nurse nurse please things have
gone kind of bad and I gotta go I got
stuff I got go deliver some soup to
somebody named Theodore nope not at all
nurse no no no I can all right what did
you get for me since you're preparing
for something you're afraid Oh mm I'm
only afraid of failing if I don't
succeed mm-hmm
then you will have sacrificed yourself
for a good cause if I sacrifice myself
there's no one to finish this sacrifice
means you've lost sometimes sometimes
it's what's needed to complete the task
at hand well let's hope it doesn't come
to that
I think I think the nurse is doing some
epic foreshadowing right there I think
it I think it might come to that pretty
sure in fact that it might exactly come
to that all right let me see if I can
take these finally smoke bombs oh I
haven't had an opportunity to use my
smoke okay so what other combat skills
could I get no I didn't because I'm not
about that
shut up see this would be super cool but
I don't think I'd ever have 75,000 shut
up shut up all right
uh yeah recovery that'd be nice I'll
speed recovery from Ridgid yeah that'd
be nice okay got that okay good oh yeah
sure okay was this total l-3 generated
from near-death yeah running I like
running I do like stamina but I can't
afford those so I'm gonna hold off All
Right see ya goodbye farewell fare thee
well
all right I wonder if the shooting
galleries opened up a bit more maybe a
cuz I got a new gun got a new gun from a
very sad reason
No okay fine then all right buh-bye now
buh-bye okay I'm out of here all right
Oh somebody if somebody made a Hibou ski
compilation on Tom Lydia yesterday and I
reblogged new super fun it's just
there's the amount of times that I say a
boo ski it's a whole area I'm hilarious
is what I'm saying I'm unbelievably
hilarious it's exactly what I'm saying
I'm great today thank you combat little
more what are you talking about
don't combat me oh yeah well you out of
your mind what are you out of your gourd
you think I do combat no get out of here
go your silliness okay we got to get
back Abu ski wait are we even going this
way
Sykes Sykes yes okay yes yes Sykes
you're still in here are you okay
probably go to a safe room and see
what's going on I will I will go to his
safe room and see what's going on I will
do that and I'm pretty sure it was this
one yeah it was this one right okay I
think it was this one
[Music]
combat Oh pish posh pish posh
this [ __ ] oh don't bring me any of that
[ __ ] need combat for boss fights
does it look like I needed combat for
boss fights I've gotten so far with what
I've had so far I don't need no combat
for no fights what are you talking about
get out of here with this go away
okay so in here oh man where'd all these
new supplies come from that doesn't seem
right take it but something tells me
oops nope not the door I was looking for
no no
go back go back go back go back back
hang on hang on okay I got a look in
here for just about anything else
syringes yes please
coffee oh oh I do want some coffee so
I'm gonna drink some coffee okay
this sweet coffee hmm I'm looking pretty
banged up and I gotta get this it's my
hand still hurts don't know why some
from the first game right I hope they're
still be bandages on it no no Oh anyway
got my coffee I'm gonna go let's get out
here okay so if I look at the map
I bet everything's on fire outside
judging by the temperature yeah so
there's something over there
Oh sanctuary hotel that's where the art
was interesante ha oh I thought that was
gonna be huh brewski
oh that guy's praying oh I wouldn't have
done it if I didn't have to Kidman I'm
gonna finish this once and for all
I'm gonna save Lily I have all the tools
I need this time okay it's important
that I know what's going on in there so
that I can help you again I do
I'll be in touch I'll get you all right
whoo hey what what
okay thought I already got you but I
don't something tells me that's not Liam
Oh potatoes over there
dumb tells me that might be someone else
is burning up some zombies who'd have
thought that lighting zombies on fire
would convert them over to your cause oh
but I see what you're reasoning with oh
that makes logical sense to me also I'm
on fire anything in the bushes okay so
I'm gonna make my way and kind of comb
through the city a bit see what I can
find hitter and tither maybe you have to
go back to the theater I'll try to make
my way back there eventually but I'm
gonna try to go for what I need first
move I in this place is unstable oh your
mistake not being on fire in all the
time all right way to grumble all the
way down can I even get to this guy
there's a tree gonna let me go through
this is like a super bush it is like a
super bush Oh No Oh No
let me through please please it's right
there Oh No
oh there we go okay easy peasy I guess
back at the bush what Oh what
whoa okay bye alright see ya I'll get
that herb later hey buddy you gonna
stand out on fire or do I have to do
something about that
Donna whoa whoa oh hi oh nutbush bush
sorry but whoa
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
worry about that well I dodge that with
my dodging skill that I have geez you
guys don't want to give up the fight I'm
out of stamina
okay I'm gonna go in here the nightmare
place didn't want to go in there but I'm
in here now are you yeah okay
no not a bit Sebastian what are you
doing who is that ah okay good for me oh
those guys are so angry I'm so angry all
the time
ah take some ambien or something I don't
know what's an anti angry pill so
stressed
oh don't hop over there okay you know
what I'm gonna go straight with the
safehouse I meant to stab somebody but
nobody wanted to get saft I think I can
stop doing that you're like the the big
Lala lady or you know you're the
laughing lady from the last time I was
here if they're dancing zombo's still
here they better still be here I'm gonna
be a lot less happy if the dancing
zombies aren't running in a circle right
over this place oh no they're gone no
they're gone
oh no oh hello okay alright then
did you see what happened to the dancing
zombies they're bad
ooh nice view though hey what's going on
down there sorry for the burp I'm just a
gross individual okay okay everything up
here
yep all right these damn [ __ ] didn't
allow me to get everything in this
building and I'm definitely gonna get
everything this building hey don't oh I
see
you're facing the other way how was your
mistake and not mine ooh slightly on
fire though okay huh had a bottle and
the plan I desperately needed those I'm
so glad I came back in here to get those
oh man that guy can hear pretty good
don't like that
who's there anything in this building
over here I just want to check
everything I want to be very thorough
because this is probably gonna be the
last episode so there's probably gonna
be the ending of the game I just want to
make sure that I have every opportunity
to give all these slides I don't want
any other collectibles I really don't
care about everything else I just want
to be able to say that I got all the
slides what are you doing in there what
are you doing in there okay fine then
carry on over here throw water on him oh
good idea
so soup autumn day even better idea now
we're talking
now we're talking about super whoo
assault rifle ammo pouch that's new okay
that's over on the other side over there
okay I don't think I can go around but I
can go this way it's naked II it's
negative ud- beauty
those clothes man these guys sure are
groaning oh no no no not today okay I'm
gonna go in here sorry you didn't see
nothing
oops I don't think there's anything new
in here but I just want to go in here oh
whoa
I probably not good
no you didn't see no way you're talking
about why are you on fire the fire it
burns oh okay good well let's just want
to kick that door for good measure
oh you know what how about how about one
of these oh that's problem precocious
job precarious prepare it's okay you
know what I'm out I don't seem to be
doing as good as I normally do against
these guys whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa there's something over
here there's something over here I can
climb over there oh boy okay so I got a
oh that's a big boy
that is a big boy I know you go blam so
don't oh oh oh oh okay all right well
first I'm gonna do this ah good
got that in hurry
all righty then well that was gross too
big ol boomer it's up Homer Boober Oh
boomer sees me look at stiffy steps
snaps no water getcha
Oh Bo to get you oh he's gonna get me
we're dwarfee don't be Glorfindel z
pocket full of posy don't go blow z come
on no no don't do it oh oh oh he's
getting is it just me or is he getting
more more more rotunda oh that hurt of
bajillions oh that's no good
that's no good you got me stuck in that
car can I help you with that
no okay let me really I'm crying it's
just really stuck my car what are you
doing you crazy up oh come on you're
right there got my car come on
there you go oh well let's see how far I
can stretch this Z all right
well setting up a nice trip wire here
whoa
I love physics systems in game alright
that's fun okay so I got that and now
all I need to do is comb the rest of the
area make my way over to the safe house
with sight see what he wants he's
plugging sending it back out again just
in case in case I'll get everything I
need it's like it's weird it's like
there's two different like
organizational objectives here there was
originally low normal okay there was
like the the corpses that were being
collected for the purposes of the
photographer guy Stefano Valentini and
now there's like the corpses that are
being gathered for the per
of Theodore and like it's wildly
different structures but you can see how
their mind kind of influences them up in
a way I mean I don't really see how a
giant exploding zombie is part of
Theodore's you know vision for the
future but you can kind of see some
influence coming through there
storage room key
okay how many supplies sweet oh hello ah
am I stuck Oh Billy Billy what's it what
is that what okay all right
that's a doom action figure that's so
cool that's so cool like that that's
good all right
storage room keep found in the corpse in
alleyway this small key opens the
storage room near the post plus office
okey dokey where is the post plus office
storage key that's so cool the doom this
is made this was published by Bethesda
who I think published the last doom and
I believe the game is made on a modified
version of the it'd engine of which that
is last step thanks a fence post plus an
office was a post post office was that
the post office is Etha said is that it
I think that might've been the post
office over there so I gotta go back to
that but I'll go back to that after I
talked to Sikes
because then Sikes might send me over
there anyway so I might as well give him
a chat hey lady lady
later today little hoodie lit all right
doodlee do
okay I believe that lady lady
the end of the world but I'm still
feeling happy do do I see something I
don't know if it's worth getting I left
goop on the ground of there I'll get it
later
did I leave I don't think I actually
made a kill over there so I don't think
what did I just get I have no idea oh
well that's something that seeing me
mmm that's peculiar okay I'm off you
can't catch me if you blow up I'm gonna
die
Kosuke no health big ol no health over
here
wonderful Oh such a good maneuver
such a good maneuver oh well did well
did okay I gotta go back in here all
right Sykes what do you want boom
alright tykes bikes bikes what is it
sorry what's so urgent are you dead in
this totally safe safe house hey Sykes
how's it going
you know before I go I'm gonna open this
box who you think the other box has
stuff in it again I bet he do who is
that a silence handgun just in case it
didn't go in here well too bad I'm too
smart for you you're here I didn't talk
to you on Sykes I'm sort of busy here
hey you're the one who told me to call
you before I left
you found your back door check it out ah
looks safe
Congrats you'll have to show me how to
use it if I need to get Lily out later
fair enough but here's the deal I'm
gonna need you to help me get out of
here first okay phew I don't know
anything about how these computers work
Sykes that's not what I need help with I
hacked the servers to access a
restricted area of stem there's a pod in
there that I'm gonna use to get out of
here
problem is the power's out there are a
bunch of those things in there too Dam
collapse is affecting the deepest parts
of stem you get the power back on and
clear the place out for me I can get the
hell out of here
again what's in it for me I'll show you
how to use the pod before I go how's
that okay
worth a try I guess thanks man
call me when it's all clear okay I gotta
tell you I was surprised to hear from
you tell me about it I've been lying low
to solve this backdoor thing but I stuck
my head out there a few times
things are going nuts what's happening
out there there's a maniac who's trying
to take over Union you were smart to
stay in here otherwise you might have
ended up flayed and tortured sounds grim
think I'll pass what's worse is that the
guy wants to get his hands on lily well
if this plan works out you'll be able to
get her to safety once you find her okay
a guy like you end up in Mobius in the
first place a guy like me what are you
trying to say I'm saying that you've got
heart and a backbone seems they prefer
their operatives to be either cold
reptiles or unquestioning followers
you're neither what did you think I
meant nothing never mind you know I
actually searched them out to try and
join wasn't easy either they know how to
hide their tracks why would you do that
they're only the most powerful
organization in the history of the world
do
well I wouldn't and you don't consider
what they do to be criminal hey it's
only criminal when it's enforced
you know what they say quis custodiet
Ipsos custodes right sure
wait for it alright ok alright then cool
well that's nice but I'm not gonna do
that now because I got other stuff to do
here and I don't want to make any final
steps towards any sort of ending until I
know exactly what I'm dealing with and I
got a mysterious key so I'm gonna take
that one up
alright that's what we're gonna do am I
still on tour no no I'm not still on
tour it's the volume still low I'm
trying my best here yeah there we go
that's about as loud as it can go
literally that's as loud as it can go
but uh I know that uh I know that some
people need to hear things oh okay I
just want to make sure that was still
going all right
Sykes you don't die I'll be back I gotta
go let me shave but uh I'll be back you
stay beautiful all right okay cool all
right how about uh baboo but a little it
have to okay pradier did it did it did
it Oh hear that music I don't want to
hear that music we gotta go okay okay
so let's take the back way back way is
covered by zombies okay oh that is a lot
of zombies you know what I might not
want to go the back way
oh boy man there's a lot of these things
oh oh well that's a problem
haha sweet manoeuvre you can't catch me
I'm the gingerbread man all right Nick
snog well we got some normal zombies
which I'll take over the flaming variety
oh well that was weird
oh one of my hands gone that's peculiar
I'm suspecting something come on you
weird wormy bastard I can't I can't duck
for cover else I'd ambush him right here
but oh that no no no you're not getting
away not that easily I think that one
might have suspected something well I'm
out of here buddy
Guddu can I roll across this hood please
tell me I can roll across this hood
nope owes a big negative on that one big
papa
oh you can't find me I'm in a bush I'm
out of stamina got a fresh dirt off Oh
hey watch it were you flinging that
thing sir ma'am I don't know okay we got
to make our way back here
okay I'm gonna check the roof of this
and then I'm gonna go over there because
I want to make sure Oh chat every team
what happened to you Chad
oh that ain't good oh hey how's it going
buddy
Alma boy you toasted my butt a bit there
let you do that yeah okay that guy means
business
a guy name means business all right so
we got that he can't get me up here
we'll go up there
I think it might be that one cuz I think
yeah that's the post office so it would
make sense whoa where did that one come
from where did that one come from okay
oh oh hey I gotta get a drink hey hold
on hold on hold on hold on Bob whoo okay
ah covered my escape at least alright
cool cool cool all right
free goop all right so this one I got a
slurp up a bit you know
the other one was fine why are those Oh
cuz you're Frozone all right
I probably could have gotten this a long
time ago no I just didn't oh no this
scene was like whoa
Oh Oh see okay this seems like one of
those places where la-la lady could
probably
ooh
Joe Gunn but I already have a shotgun
full barreled shotgun longer range to do
- uh-oh I didn't know that my current
shotgun was a snub nose all righty then
then I'm just gonna why wouldn't I do
that right oh it is a snubby type
shotgun okay well I'm gonna do this one
then is there any reason not to that one
cuz it seems like seems like that's
pretty good looks like that's pretty
good yeah I'm gonna take that one does
seem pretty good okay yeah yeah why not
okay all right good for me got a better
shotgun yeah probably the roof probably
good gotten and a long time ago doodlee
do I don't like those sounds oh cool all
these supplies Oh
Chad Chad every teen I'm sorry
I'm so sorry alright alright you need
some water some aspirin maybe to take
care of that okay oh hi wait wait that's
not fair Wow Wow
well this is highly irregular
Wow okay you know what I'm gonna you you
just earned yourself a spanking mister
all right guess who's about to get their
ass kicked by me aggressively cuz I'm
gonna stab ya
come here where'd you go are you buddy
come on come on come on take time out oh
okay well this is precarious oh you made
a mistake oh you made a horrible hair
you made a Oh allergic to soap oh he
might lay back on fire though wait is
there something in there there's a
zombie in that car oh the corpse oh I
thought the corpse is like ah si si ah
Garbo Garbo maybe he's gonna turn back
off before he comes around and super
your kidneys superior brain all right
come over here buddy
hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
come on yeah that's right oh I'm
slurping up all your friends soup you
might want to do something okay
you know sir I don't think you're taking
this situation very seriously I'm gonna
need you to okay well that's all right
let's not be
oh come on did that get you oh wait did
you can see a harpoon sticking out of
his neck like hey wait a minute
who did that come on
I'm right here you dick there he is
brilli there I've spotted him all right
I want to really get this I don't know
about that one I just want to kick sure
you did you lost him I don't know where
he was when I dumped oh come on why
can't I scoop up it didn't let me shoot
them I don't know about that one
Esmond you tried real hard you got
nowhere
this freakin idiot maybe if you weren't
blind you know whatever it's fine
I did I I taught him a lesson or two
now I'm gonna honk the horn of
celebration and I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be on my way I'll come back over here if
you want another war Boone hey okay
let's see I always do some shotgun
shells but it's all good because I'm
getting tons of gunpowder I've got 151
so i can graft up pretty much anything
that I could possibly want but now oh
wait what hey hey hey come on now don't
be silly Billy
no silly Billy up in here I want to be
able to soup you but you don't seem to
be too receptive to soup uh no come over
oh I see how it is you want to get your
ass kicked again
oh how about a bottle I don't want to
embrace his fame do I get yeah I think I
got him
hey come on over here come everybody
whoops that was premature sorry where
are you going I'm back here alright fine
then you're gonna get one you know what
this guy's an [ __ ] all right whatever
Oh
yeah I got really is an [ __ ] wait why
is it both coming for me wait that
doesn't make any sense he's the one who
flamed you alright fine I'm out here
maneuver all right so should I go I'm
thinking that I should do this this
seems more like a side quest than the
other one so I'm figuring that I should
go in here first yeah so rifle ammo
pinch these come from oh hell yeah
that's right there and that's right
there okay don't do that I guess we're
in here was it right at the end there Oh
kind of cleared out a bit so it's pretty
nice you're another one over there
Oh
whoa whoa whoa these guys are turning
around very this way oh hey ho hey come
on don't make me waste ammo on you no no
no no no no let me just Pat this ass and
I'm gonna be on my way okay okay that's
all I want to do all right got it
whoa nope that's not what I want okay
all right okay all right now I'm on my
way
I'll get the I'll get the rifle ammo
pouch later all right all right let's do
this
Sikes I'm ready don't ask me what I just
did but I really riled them all up out
there and killed none I think you're
gonna be fine don't worry they're all
angry they all saw me coming in this
place so you get your gun and you get
ready to shoot him I funneled them real
right down that hallway there to spray
this up I know you're armored you think
it's real tough here but just kind of
spray along that wall don't worry
bullets will punch right through that
bad boy let me suck him tell me nope
nope okay nothing to do all right
actually before I do that let me go in
here because I I got so now you know
what I've got I've been going in there
so many times let's get down to business
here all right we're going we're going
for it
we're going for it I need to kill the
flamethrower guy oh because he would
have flamethrower parts wouldn't he
I'll get that later I'll get it later
I'll get it I'll get it I'll kill him oh
oh oh I'll kill him all right don't
worry I'll kill him
I'll get him all right I'll get him but
I'll get him later because I don't think
this will be lead to the end oh he'll be
out there he'll still be there I want to
get back don't worry he'll still bill
you'll still be there do the
experimental wing the where is this in
relation to everything else
nowhere okay there's apparently nowhere
in relation to anything else in the
marrow fancy pop escape Sebastian
Castellanos here ready and willing hello
hello looks abandoned spooky ooh just
got to take care of whatever's down here
to get the power back on mm-hmm spook
alicia's if there's a vent over there
Ibuki no no haboos King all right well
that's a lot of bodies and some Zombo
bodies over there but I'm gonna crawl in
the nice safe not spooky hole whoo oh
how did you die sir
hey sorry I got you through that door
you wanted that so badly so I thought
I'd help you out you know those through
that door that you wanted to wimp WOM so
badly nothing all right
maybe this isn't easy enough task as it
is I'm pretty good at dispatching the
normal zombo's turnaround so I guess I
couldn't put the normal way depends
where you go next
ah okay you're not gonna go all the way
I'll get out gonna open that door
no no no no no you didn't see nothing
what are you talking about
whoa what are you talking about I'd take
a pause there for a second nope that's
hot damn it's not I keep getting these
not haidle walls
[Music]
Oh
now I got them stuck in both ways oh
that's that's not good don't worry it's
all good you threw your ax you idiot
I got this one red hot soup now okay
Sebastian hey lady where you at come
around that corner there we go ah
hey lady wake up and smell that's what
the hockey hack what the heck you scared
me it wasn't supposed to go down like
that
hey do you see me you see me lady this
see me you see me
oh whoa Lord hey lady stop that don't be
a dummy crazy come on this one's this
one's precocious like I admit this one
is this one is very uh intelligent this
one knows what's up
ready then why is this one giving me
someone such a headache oh yeah I get
frustrated okay I just come over here so
I can soup yeah yeah yeah okay come over
here come over here okay your gob okay
here we go
I don't know I don't know why that was
so problematic for me
no well got done I need a work bench
soon to be able to craft up some bullets
oh no someone lied to me alrighty then
wait where am I what this is not where I
am experimental wing here we go
Oh ahh wait was what I needed in here Oh
ahh convenient alright
and three two four that's five okay yeah
PUD
[Applause]
huh
all right conundrum oh yeah oh yeah they
all know they all know they all know oh
they all know they all know okay they
all know but they can't follow me career
I know that for a fact I'm sure you're
in your dick now I can't shoot from here
okay wow that was a problem huh Sykes
it's all clear it's all clear buddy
hopefully you got the power on but I
gotta take care of all those things
before calling Sykes you don't know that
you don't know that at all all right
interesting Oh interesting okay all
right got clear all those things out huh
let me just use one of this bad boy
actually ah
that's the good [ __ ] okay where did you
guys go they're all in there right they
should be all in there so I just gotta
take care of them all and then I'm gonna
get through and see what's going on with
this story here dude dude dude dude
easy soupy oh you guys both shouldn't
have your back turned like that that's
the mistake secret hole in my sneaky
hole this is what I call my surprise
hole I popped my hat on go boo and then
you never know what happened to you I
mean you'll you'll know because you'll
die no see that would have been a
mistake
one of those miss stock is come on Dora
come on I got free appetizers here
all-you-can-eat buffet Oh soup womp womp
all right so I got two more over there
again with their backs turned
mysteriously a very very very convenient
for me very very convenient okay
you stay right there your friend won't
know a thing okay
Tom app your friend and it all better
run too mysterious substance Gil oh he
doesn't even know it was like what was
that it was all a soupy blur I don't
know Robert look where is what I can't
believe it I'm flabbergasted I'm just
completely at a loss oh I'm not at a
loss anymore I know exactly what go down
Oh
come here come on little closer ha
Oh No what was that it was all oh shoot
we bar all right there you go little
poodle got that all right so that's done
I think it's all clear down now that
would be the last one right I think
anyway he couldn't take care of that
Sikes that lazy sack of crap he could
have done that
all right Sykes it's all clear for you
all right do I got to go back and tell
them or is there another place over here
research and development no I think
that's pretty much everything right that
would be everything right ooh
no I got a column from in here okay Oh
better call Sykes better call Thanks are
you gonna call sex oh okay oh the green
soup you inject into your brain to
upgrade you're not combat skills
literally anything becomes wouldn't been
able to do it without you I know sure
this is gonna work no but staying in
here isn't gonna do me any good anything
is worth a try at this point huh okay
it's all set right when you bring Lily
back here there's a timer right here
turn it a quarter rotation and then you
just press this button it'll give you 60
seconds to climb into the pot you both
should be able to fit in it together
I don't know Sykes I got a bad feeling
about this
look man I know what I'm doing okay
maybe you should hold off on this help
me find Lily and then we can all find
another way out of here I feel for you
man I really do but I'm doing the best
thing I can do for you by getting this
pod operational okay if you say so
wish me luck Sebastian no apparently no
luck for you wait this doesn't make
sense but their bodies in the real world
are still in the pods in the center of
Mobius how are they gonna sneak out when
they suddenly wake up okay I left you
something in there for helping me now
I've got a bad feeling about this
see you on the other side Sebastian
that was not what that did what see you
on the other right that sounds like
death sounds a lot like death and dying
okay goodbye yeah he's gone I wonder if
it worked left left
so in there in there in there okay in
there did it work --sykes okay alright
that's has been declared a failure
despite a 25 percent success rate the
decision has been made to discontinue
research one in four test subjects made
the trip back successfully the other
three simply ceased to be we believe
that the other 75% have been lost in an
uncharted sub level of a dream within
the dream twenty five percent chance of
success I'm not gonna risk Lily's life
like that
what hope Sykes is out in the real world
one in four chance maybe he'll get lucky
what what well that wasn't there before
no that wasn't even something that I
could read before because I remember I
went in this room and I looked all
around it this was not here before this
was not on top of that box that wasn't
there before that was only meant to be
read after the fact that's on four sites
I bet he met whoa another shotgun
twice the barrels twice the Buckshot
twice the damage oh well I do like to
use it up close and personal so to be
perfectly honest that's kind of my style
if I just get real up close to the uh
the UH the flamethrower guy and I just
give him a double-barreled dose full of
this that's some good stuff you know
what I'm saying so I keep that one on my
hotkey and I'll keep this one in the
middle maybe that's what I should do you
know just keep the the hotkey ones the
good ones and then everything else I can
deal with
elsewise but that's good right I think
it's good yeah ok all right well Sykes
probably dead let's you know I you know
I ordinarily I want to be optimistic
about those things with sex's probably
extremely dead problem and probably not
even daddy's probably in that lower
level but yeah I'm not gonna risk I'm
gonna risk Lilly like that yeah all
right
ok we're done here sorry Sykes but
thanks for the slide projector hope you
didn't die all right now I got a
double-barrel dose of soup I just fill
both chambers with soup I'm like right
up next to a zombie they're like no
please don't
all right Roy Roy and I'm like ah two
cans of Campbell's right now go it right
there let's go be out go does Sykes is
dead you know I honestly wouldn't know I
have no idea I don't know no no but I'm
gonna I'm gonna take care of this I'm
gonna take the take the flamethrower guy
out for a nice lovely soup dinner and
it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
I was gonna love it he's gonna he's not
a little bit but I were gonna love it
all right let's go look at the slide
lady hello Eddy Katie Katie Katie Katie
Katie and what's this one all about
alright only one left
woo you around Kidman stem this is twice
now it's failed a machine that puts you
inside other people's heads who decided
it was something anyone needed I don't
want to know what's in another person's
head I learned that the last time
potential to enslave everybody you mean
I don't know about that don't tell me
you buy into that whole unifying mankind
thing Vic or Mobius either way nobody
should have their hands on this
technology it's too powerful and power
tends to get abused well what happens
with if everyone's united in stem who's
gonna feed their like normal bodies
who's gonna do that who's gonna keep
that alive cuz he you know still a human
vice don't need to eat input why are you
look good he's for me this time huh
what is it you want me to follow you
what
you want me to sit in the chair yargh Oh
congratulations Sebastian you have
almost completed the inner journey that
you began so long ago you have faced
down your own demons you have risked a
great harm to emerge triumphant
but there is still a memory that you've
refused to confront what do you mean so
the nurse is the cat this will help you
the nurse has been the cat the whole
time little weird already then but okay
there's a last one I thought that I
thought it was gonna be more of a hunt
than that all right all right nice hey
nurse cat nurse cat you're less cute now
that I know that they're the same like
red band in her hair that's what they
were showing okay
all right okay Oh Joe Joe no Joe Joseph
oh my partner Joe Joe under all this
time there's something we've never
talked about Hey not what who Joseph I
never had the opportunity to make amends
about that things were confusing after
beacon I should have tried to get
answers about what happened I mean I
know what happened don't worry I can't
follow you for what you did
but I still blame myself for his death
why not you'd prefer that I blame you
you're the one who actually killed them
no I couldn't I saw you shoot up Kidman
but what what no it can't
what happened to him where is he
you bet we're gonna talk later Joe Joe
Joe Joe Joe Joe he's alive I knew it I
knew it I knew it
hmm I knew it I knew it Jojo is this Joe
Joe's desk is this way is this Joe Joe's
desk
Joe Joe is it your stuff but these are
sweet cigarettes well they smell at you
Oh Joe Joe what is that
Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
hey huh huh
Oh Sykes oops I told you to be careful
with that thing Sykes hope you made it
out maybe you never know okay but
Georgia Oh where's that doll
I kept the doll there there's oh yeah
the weird thing yeah Joe Joe go go oh
wow
thank you whoo thank you nurse you think
Joe Joe stuck in here you think Joe
Joe's been stuck in stem I bet he's been
surviving this whole time because Joe
Joe is a freakin badass if he he can
survive a freakin harpoon through the
brain I'm pretty sure Egon survived a
few years inside a stem
that's the Joe Joe I know No Oh Joe Joe
oh I should upgrade this thing it's like
I got so many upgrade parts why not
I'm so happy I've never been this happy
in my life oh so happy you speed that's
good
I've got so many parts I might as well
move to to get bad why would I want that
up me dad that bad I mean I've got a lot
of high-grade weapon parts but firing
rate with cheese good god that's so fast
do I need that fast I don't know if I do
I don't know waste ammo that quickly Oh
Joe Joe I love you Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe I miss ya okay let's hold off on
that more firepower to this thing that's
why not I mean there's no point in
holding off that's why I'm getting these
things because yeah like why bother
holding off oh that would be that'd be
nice but I don't have that Oh Joe
I missed where is he
you think he's okay you think he's
thinking about me guys I hope he's got a
lot of know I don't know but he's got a
lot of soup but you know what I mean
hope he's got a lot of you know not not
soup in the brain one in it time good
god how am I gonna screw that I'm good
with the handgun
alright fine imma load up on these bad
boys cuz I guess so much of this [ __ ]
alright I'm gonna get more foon's or
those I can make so I should field craft
those is what I should do BAM
freezy bolt yes please I need that for
the dude there we go
medical kit yep there we go let's get
more shotgun shells and boom okay we're
good we're good we're good we're good
for now
alright and then let's stuff stuff
inside my brain and then we outie we
outta here we outta of the hearer
alright slam that on the head okay cool
I see you're in need of my services
again now do you know where Joseph is do
you know where Joe's Jojo is do you know
no no Joe don't this is relaxing what
shut up shut up it doesn't have another
key so I gotta go with this I could have
grabbed that in that kid instead of
being cautious shut up but you can't
avoid fighting forever
God maybe you should think about adding
some combat skill shut up
Oh Andy dandy I can get that so if I
almost die I'll just use a syringe
instead emergency drugs that's probably
good go with that one laughs okay that's
good
all right good for me health I can't get
that what is this recover from near
death status combat all right fine a
little bit of combat but not a lot okay
not a lot wish I had more stealth
abilities to give cuz that's what I
really want here alright see ya
a nerd Zee Jojo we got it okay we're
gonna get it we gotta you gotta get Jojo
gotta save him save him gotta save Jojo
I know he's in here he must be in the
lower level do you think that's that's
where people go when they die in stem do
you think they go to that lower level
that you can't escape from it's like
hell or heaven but for here you think
that's it do we think I gotta go down
there maybe lilial get out cuz she's
lucky and I won't oh oh oh I'm just
gonna go with this here because that's
all I really want yeah I'll switch back
if I need some longer range but that'll
be very case dependent but Oh Jojo
please come back tell me you're okay oh
please god I've got so many guns on me
boom alright where are you at
flamethrower man I've got a delivery for
you oh do I have a delivery for you why
here you where you at buddy boo oh there
you are
all right hey why don't you come over
with me to a secret area that only we
will know about actually or I could just
freezable you also an option
Oh Doh what was that weird huh okay
anyway Haley have you seen this wait
what was that Oh stabby hell yeah oh
cool come over here hey dude you don't
know about that okay well good thing I
stopped ow
no let me see so let me through here
thank you
hey buddy buddy come over here there's
some frizzy things that I need you to
see oh I need you to see him anything
you need you to see him real good
hey but we're just get over here I'm
gonna shoot you come on come on buddy
what was that weird
come here uh-huh
Jesus slowpoke here I just get over here
what okay before I could what are you
going in there what what you idiot I'm
in here
this stupid sack of [ __ ] who is that oh
maybe I should take this mask off I am
pretty blah
I will readily admit I can't see [ __ ]
damn what this guy's deal buddy Brando
right here bring your face so you feel
the bullets you feel those okay cool Oh
dick there buddy buddy there we go okay
here we are
all right we've finally reached our
destination okay and okay thank you for
cooperating friend oh okay why can't I
status you now Oh
all right whatever Wow
don't be maybe only when I frizzy Boldin
hey buddy buddy buddy I don't know about
that I'm pretty clean as it is me giving
no I won't let me do it all right well
whoa what the hell we missed us
point-blank oh whoa oh well use
flamethrower got busted you think I
shouldn't have done that
no no no dude dude dude dude dude dude
what this guy is so stupid are you going
back in that building and you're so
skill I what why dude I'm right here
dude please friend I wanna I just want
to make sure you're eating properly
that's all I want that's all I've ever
wanted
oh there is fire did someone Honka [ __ ]
god damn it stop getting up on that Wow
I don't know what's going on it's like
when I want to run away they're like
locked on target when I want to get them
over here they can't be bothered Wow
yeah I probably just broke the
flamethrower parts I probably did dude
where are you
yeah I'll burn the burner get it I'll
burn all right cool hope well friends
there we go the chase is on
oh he fast now alright give me this come
here on a Facebook okay I thought that
might have like stunned here some whoa
with this guy's quick oh whoa hey whoa
whoa I'm dancing up tiptoe dancing no no
wha huddle adieu
okay I'm sorry father I lost him speedy
these making me lose all my bullets
alright how about we slow you down just
a smidge please just stab them I want it
up why I didn't reload well that's fun
good God
please it's gonna take will I be
you will shut up hopefully there we go
there we go finally good god man
good God alright well yeah I broke those
so that was my bad
that was my bad oh I need they're almost
there yeah ah I can't believe that that
is amazing
ah sweet bushes ah stealth bushes I love
oh he just goes like ah oh yeah I'll get
through this bush and then never does it
again like the first time he goes in the
bush wait
was first time he goes in the bush he's
just like gotta get him out of my face
nope he's not gonna do this alright
whatever it was funny I swear it was
funny I promise okay so now we just
gotta finish this fight after making
this uh after we make this like that's
it I've got all the slides and that's
all I really wanted because I just
wanted to know that Joe Joe was alive oh
and now I'm happier than I ever could be
so let's finish this
like let's legitimately finishes I gotta
go back into uh gonna go back in the
world to get the workbench to be able to
finish it but that's it that's it got
what I need it right
what oh I need to I need what excuse me
what what what I don't have enough
bullets for that whoop
stupid [ __ ] oh you poop was there
another one or something oh there is oh
you you I don't like you at all and you
know what I'm gonna this guy this guy
this guy thinks he can pull it faster
Dan he I don't know about that whoa I
don't think I did that I think he knows
I think he knows guys he knows he knows
he knows guys guys who knows
that hurts you donut and get one right
here knock all right in your nose holes
oh boy oh geez that didn't slow nothing
oh ye
ah that hurts you okay I don't know how
many it's gonna take to kill you but I'm
just gonna keep firing that's uh how do
you do the fireball things Oh Clank OH
I'm gonna execute you I'm gonna ask you
oh no no not cook the dog no I don't
think so
okay well out of that I only got one of
these but maybe I'll it'll pretend like
it's a double bar I think I can maybe I
can do under these vinegars nope that's
a negative
okay well no that's not okay I'm out of
that I'm out of that time for the
machine gun no I don't think so and you
also need to take one of these bad boys
let's do a little bit of that hog yeah
that's good stuff all right
okay well he knows how to take cover
barrel crew scary eerie
see this is why Toto couldn't kill
anything with this thing it's fiddly
week and I'm officially out of
everything how where have I gone whoa
cool mist apparently can I please please
can I please can i oh it was right there
I saw it I saw it it was right there it
was right there it was right there it
was there it was there I saw it there
this is so hard ah got you this time ah
suped you're right in the kidney give me
that [ __ ] give me that [ __ ] give me that
[ __ ] that's it the last piece I need all
right cool
got that go why am I even using this I
don't even know if Theodore is gonna be
vulnerable to fire this is this is like
this took all of my ammo so this better
be worth it if it's not worth it I'm
gonna be so pissed imma be so pissed and
it better have unlimited ammo that's
what I guess it because I don't know I'm
gonna craft up more flamethrower ammo
cuz they seem to have unlimited ammo why
don't I get unlimited ammo so I got say
about that that [ __ ] alright here we go
got it oh yeah there we go there we go
this odd weapon can be used to quickly
fill an area with flaming fluid it's
heavy and cumbersome enough to restrict
movement fuel will be loaded into flame
there immediately upon crafting cue will
stow the flamethrower on your back
allowing you to move more freely okay
okay
[Music]
ah
sneak kills that's why you all are
saying upgrade my smoke uh okay I find
it known that I would have done that oh
yeah Moke becomes poisonous oh that's
that's really nice
okay anyway but but but
maybe if I go outside I guess you
couldn't equip it in the safe house I
guess I want to burn down okay okay ah
no nope
there there it is oh come on to Papa
come o to Papa
if you want to get fire why why this the
why though why though I'm confused
wait was that always there before did
that always that always collapse I can't
remember I wasn't looking at it
alright the ones to get some flamin hot
soup I don't know I have an accident
when I'm holding this like see I'm I
don't have an accent when I'm not
holding it but suddenly when I am
holding it I have two accent you want
some hot soup it is too respite see I
don't know why that's just weird it just
like has to be that way ah you want a
little taste of their flaming soup let's
see the range on this bad boy okay not
quite at ranch birth ah you're unfair
now solve your problem that was
shockingly effective for that guy
alrighty then
weird but okay don't know why like
literally that shouldn't have an accent
but it just does I can't help that
that's just what my brain goes to it's
like one of those nervous tics that you
just can't control get the flamethrower
you got to talk in that accent it's a
fact
alright anyway let's get over to where
we were gonna go
Thank You ooh more weapon parts yes
please any more of those I need to
upgrade my smoke bombs because if I'd
have been doing that from the beginning
I would have been able to do more sneak
kills because but I'm dumb all right ha
ha I wonder what would happen if I went
all the way back through the marrow to
try to go to like the original places I
don't even know if you could but I'm
just curious about it if you go to like
Liam safe house like way way but could
you even go I don't know if the marrow
is like closed off now I think it might
be there might have been something that
was just like completely shut down that
you couldn't get through do anything
over here there was something over here
before over here now oh yeah I wanted to
go back to the theater before I actually
move on because I wanted to see if there
was anything at the theater waiting for
me God the three of you it's like odd
numbers of things come out here
all right Oh big guy I something tells
me the flamethrower ain't gonna work too
good on these guys right here but come
on come on come on come on oh he's out
of range for supermoto I don't think
he's within range whoo I'm gonna go with
a no on that one
oh why Ben oh boy oh boy oh boy Wow okay
that's unnecessary Oh big boomer boy
last your friends please
yeah keep charging that that's gonna
work
I've got nothing I've got so much
nothing whoa dudes me pardon me
okay we're good ah looks like somebody
needs a little dose of souping oh I
can't even crowds will not do this but
that's all right you want some soup hot
soup coming your way all right
gun powder please yes please all those
things give six gunpowder that's a whole
shotgun shell might as well excuse me
would you like some soup can I hit you
with this over there well yes I can all
right that guy just exploded all of a
sudden those weird
yeah you better whoa bush save me bush
push save save me Bush bush please good
you you have to higher tolerance for the
spicy suit all right I'm just gonna get
this last guy cuz I'm spiteful
okay that's a good [ __ ] okay
got those guys down I'm just gonna check
the theater real quick because I bet I
bet there's something there there would
be right
maybe I mean if you think about it if
you think about it you remember how I
killed my own my own version of me that
was trapped in here like I did right I
did let me just grab this real quick and
that was super weird at the time but
when you think about it there's another
guy out there why are there so many of
those guys and whatever but when you
think about it in relation to everything
that's they're talking about here this
weird sublevel of stem like the levels
of stem that they're talking about
almost inception kind of like dream
within a dream kind of things you know
the principal is still kind of the same
time is all wishy-washy chat every teen
and Steve every teen oh no oh yeah but
it's weird like the whole thing that
where there was a part of me that was
locked down in there what does that even
mean
a part of me locked in stem how did I
like how do I feel that how does that
affect me like across time and space
like stem somehow reaches I mean I know
stem is like is Wireless component to it
where it was able to be like projected
into people's minds or people's minds
rather were projected into the stem
system but moreover how after I beat
ruvik and kind of destroyed the system
how was it part of me still stuck in
there like that's the fascinating thing
people can be trapped in here like death
like whatever you want to call it in the
normal world of where you know what
happens after death in here what happens
after death
maybe you get trapped deeper down than
you think you know what I mean
maybe people don't really die maybe I
maybe all the deaths like you know I'm
destiny like uh you uh you you die but
you respond like that's part of the
story maybe that's maybe it's similar
here you know what I mean yeah I don't
know more bullets not that I'm gonna get
more bullets I've never even found
bullets for that thing it's a good just
got a crap tomb but now am I gonna do
that when I don't have enough supplies
alright anyway also I want to say
they've done a really really really good
job in this game of balancing how much
ammo they give me versus what I need you
know what I mean it's always been crisis
but I've always had just enough to get
through each obstacle and I can really
appreciate that because that's a hard
thing to do in a game like difficulty
curves are hard and especially like I
get better throughout this game like
where I am now versus the beginning I'm
weight higher skill wise Claire Hoffman
they done with your tweaks okay I'm
sending you the coordinates yeah but
maybe maybe something in here is kind of
the same but yeah Amma's been really
good and the gameplay has been super fun
I've never been bored whoa
well here it is okay alright then you
know what what is it it's a portable
field stabilizer O'Neill must have been
working on it before Theodore changed
him it creates a small area of
stabilization that should keep the fire
away
how small its circumference is about as
big as a safe house big enough to
protect me
good how's it work drop it on my back
tough part
it's a prototype so it's a little
temperamental I have to operate it ah
you carry on is for it to go on the
fritz while you're in a wall aflame I
can't let you do that it's too dangerous
so is staying here if you can't get
inside besides I'm sick of hiding the
only way we're gonna get through this is
if we work together it's the only way to
save Lille
and what if you need emergency
psychoanalysis ah who's gonna help you
then you know just what to say to
convince me Hoffmann of course I do
I'm the team psychologist the team
psychologist you might want to prepare
for this let me know when you're ready
to go okay well I prepared about as much
as I can prepare so I don't know how
much more I could possibly do thanks for
the bag of supplies you're much better
at scavenging than I am Hoffman's
Journal this handwriting is hard to
decipher but with effort you manage to
read the most recent entry Liam
transforming was horrifying yet
fascinating it with far beyond our
linguistic programming
Theodore's words did more than influence
Liam they physically torment transformed
him no wonder Theodore wants to control
over stem it his am flight is already
formidable influential prowess the
things he could do in here Sebastian
personality isn't as weak as Liam's was
but he still suffers from unresolved
trauma Theodore will no doubt try to use
his new abilities to break sebastian
down i just hope that he's strong enough
to resist oh oh I am sorry for reading
your journal you're looking right at me
so I'm assuming you knew that I was
reading that hey is there any more soup
in there I hope so hoping not a bomb
yep okay got the few huh I Whangdoodle
this machine so hard I got the fuses out
of it
waffle ooh ah that's a skull that wait
let me get a good closer look at that
one let me reload mmm here's my sniper
rifle
yeah let me get a closer look at that
yep yeah let me look into that I can't
look
Oh trust me when I say it's probably a
skull Wham any more skulls in there nope
how about you you got a skull
all right cool okay all right see you
I'm gonna check upstairs real quick and
then I'm gonna move on because I think
that is all there is to this right now
and then I think we're gonna get to the
end of the game I'm pretty sure we're
gonna reach the end of this game you
have that painting not there anymore
good but yeah nothing else no aah
I thought there might have been like
some color commentary of what's going on
here all right here we go the real deal
the real spanking a moonbow real wampa
dee dum patty
the real Whangdoodle flaying doodle let
me go in the mirror first cuz I just
need to craft up whatever I can I'm
gonna use all of my crafting mats that I
have left I must save one last time but
is it I think this is it I think this is
it it's not it then I'm gravely mistaken
in its a problem but I think this is it
maybe what else when I craft I don't
know if I can upgrade anything more like
I don't have any of the rifle bullets so
what's even the point and I guess I'll
just get him as I go along but Mike this
is upgraded to maximum capacity the
shotgun could use more firepower I guess
but I don't think I have enough to get
the smoke bomb there cuz that might be
nice but I don't know how much use it'll
be yeah I need I would need 550 i 410 I
might have another opportunity later I'm
gonna hold off on the upgrades I'm just
gonna spend all my all this and the
flamethrower poom bolts need those all
of those lamb ok explosive bolts good
they're good they're good there I've got
one in the air
I'm just gonna crap me up some handgun
bullets but that's about it that's all I
can do
kind of like seven it's gotta be sparing
about that try to soup as many people as
possible and then we're gonna go hey
nice guy final words of encouragement
finally we're final words huh yeah yeah
final words how am I ever good okay
maybe not
final words maybe this isn't the final
thing because if it was the final thing
then you would think that you would have
some kind of like final finale okay
maybe it's not the final thing maybe I'm
this left I'm being an idiot maybe I'm
being a big dumb do if you do okay maybe
I'm being a big dumb doof okay I'm being
a little overeager beaver
okay but either way I gotta go for this
I wish I had some coffee oh well I'm
gonna do what you gotta do
hey lady I'm ready Sebastian yes I am
yeah I'm ready
all right II often let's do this let's
do this lead the way
okay that's me I don't know if I'll be
able to sneak with you uh holding that
thing I'll try my best I'll try my best
I'll try my best Wow flame okay
I'll have to carry and operate it from
here it should protect us from the fire
but it won't stop those things in there
from trying to kill us okay don't worry
I'll take care of them I've got seven
bullets to my name I got him
you think I don't got him oh I got him
look some magic yeah now that I think
about it I probably should have just to
make sure to stay inside the dome come
on I am coming on okay wait let me uh I
got change this to long-range oh these
flames oh I've got bullets still in
these things wait do I bullets still in
oh I do there it all oh there's clips in
there whoa whoa ah this clips still in
there
Oh Oh interesting okay that changes do i
stub I still have a full clip in my
sawed-off and my ball door okay all
right that's good to know that is very
good to know ah but let me take one of
these bad boys it's gonna be a gosh
shoot up with some heroin all right oh
that's good to know
okay all right Oh bullets
oh sorry thank goodness you had 35 of
those bad boys all right let me get the
soup real quick what are you collecting
their delicious brain goop why I don't
know
Bill's important oh boy another one
watch your back Hoffman where Oh good
thing they're everywhere where okay
Oh cake
more oh I see you
got him okay
whoa whoa wait whoa didn't see that Tim
see that oh good
cool he's afraid uh-oh
sweetly soup why do you call it soup I
know I'm weird I've been in stem a lot
really affects my brain for some reason
I see a restaurant oh really I see
living hell Oh restaurant I'm a server
I guess people's soup that's all I do
we're almost there
can you fix it I'm trying
you think I'm a better shot than I once
was
I should miss i spoke too soon uh-oh
she's dead she's dead
often I'm sorry that was that was my bad
that was my bad
oh come powder thank you
oh okay that was close Oh
Shoop Shoop Shoop Shoop
each
we've got that's weird got a big guy
without a boomy whoo yes please yes yes
come on open it there we go
give me that Oh frizzy bones I guess
those would be handy that sounds like
you're gonna be sacrificing yourself
somehow which I don't like I need that
yeah I do need one of those okay look I
got I need another hit
sorry just I'm very addicted okay I
don't think I can like I don't think I
can kill them before they like whoa
start charging whoa
good thing they're roar pull gun okay
you tense I think my leg did a thing
there hey I'm out of bullets on that one
that's okay hey huffing you anymore
sweet delicious bullets got any more of
those that'll be awfully awfully useful
I got ten left in this silence bad boy
in my quiet soup shooter my stealth soup
come on more soup more sip tip tip tip a
shotgun okay I'm just gonna Ford those
because if I can get through this with
pistols I'll be very happy
okay
all right one leg that's not good
okay how about one of these no not the
double ah I don't want the double barrel
I just want happy fourth of July oh oh
come on I can play the frequency game
better than you can
I got it
why did we need a cutscene gotta go now
oh he's as bad a shot as I am run now
we're oh okay well I'm believe it or not
I'm not playing this anymore guys I know
this seems like my levels of ineptitude
but
oh no that's not good uh-oh go Sebastian
go you better go back for her Sebastian
don't do it no Sebastian Sebastian it on
toxic off man
what what you sighs what did you die
what Hoffman no it was literally nothing
I could have done more I tripped
goddamnit you freaking
I'm disappointed in you Sebastian I'm
very disappointed in you got a freaking
game logic I'll make him pay I promise
it's fine it's fine I get it it's fine
it's fine cuz they were totally fine I'm
the only one left oh but he's not gonna
stop me all right I'm gonna stab the
[ __ ] out of Theodore God coz who's like
I told her to run why would I be going
ahead of her number one you'd if you're
defending someone you don't run ahead of
them number two I'm very clearly
could've helped so much time oh whatever
it's fine it's all good I'm not upset
oh excuse me sorry you know there's
bottles here and some stealth elements
here I'm thinking that I'm gonna have to
sneak snog something here okay what do
we got
it's okay press f to pay respects an F
to pay your respects everybody please
smash that like button to pay your
respect everyone please ding that Bell
ding that sweet Bell for respect oh god
I want to hear the chimes across the
nation just ding ding a ling ding ding
ding oh please smash that subscribe
button to pay your respects
oh god weeping over here oh I hear the
bell chimes I hear the bell oh you're
doing it so good guys oh god I'm so
proud of all of you for thinking that
sweet ding dong er to pay your respects
oh please Yukiko no no no no no what we
do without you kick off and we're just
go on thanks for building that time
machine we're gonna walk on without you
you're ringing those bells up or
wherever people go when they die in stem
you know probably he'll probably help
okay anyway nothing else here this place
Union has incredible potential and
Moebius wasted they failed to understand
the magnitude of what they created
imagine an entire world of converts
their memories overwritten and
reprogrammed all connected to a central
mind the core my commands traveling at
the speed of thought and accepted
without question I could build my own
spiritual utopia in days instead of
decades okay alright then surprisingly
I've gone I've almost got all the files
alrighty then
peekaboo everyone press B to blow your
respects
press B to blow your respects towards
Yukiko up in heaven ever press B to bail
your respects press s to sub your
respects
Oh God so much respect flowing out
through you guys I I feel it I feel it
all it's so proud of you so proud of
everything you've done in here do I map
data no okay all right that anyway
carrying on there any other goodies that
I haven't gotten yet good I'm proud of
you guys I'm so proud got him proud bang
on the on the plus side we know that
Jojo is still alive and we did see
someone who hey that's fun okay then oh
if only I had assault rifle ammo which I
don't have none of that and gun bullets
the only yeah I've never even picked up
assault rifle ammo it's only been
handgun bullets that's a lot of a OSHA's
all right oh ah
well test okay all right well whatever
that is take that pipe you're not using
it are you know about this one you using
this oh sorry about that Larry are you
all right down there okay you stay chill
you stay totally cool all right you get
fresh beautiful okay bye
I'm gonna see before I uh actually no no
that's probably everything for now I'll
explore later I just want to go in here
just in case hey some bad happen back
there is Brad bad yeah bad okay I've
gotten all that stuff what else do I
need
that's what oh I can do the smoke bomb
upgrade that's nice
okay smoke bomb that that would be
lovely
oops oh no wait I need oh I need a
hundred more I just don't have enough Oh
close close close close but not quite
you're Wells gonna craft more handgun
bullets assault rifle cartridges would
be nice but again I'm hoping I'll get
those in real life nurse do you have
anything to say about all this conundrum
everything's pretty terrible in here
I've got 20,000 soup but my brain don't
take too kindly to anything happening
not looking so good let me help you
please yes hmm another sacrifice has
gotten you this far damn it why did she
have to die my question exactly I've
lost them all the tragedy but they died
honorably one can only hope the
trade-off is worth it right it has to be
otherwise they died for nothing I can't
bear to think of that then you owe it to
them to see this through to save her so
that their sacrifice wasn't in vain yeah
you're right your wrongs do this I need
all the help I can get at this point
yeah all the help we can get we can do
this there's nothing wrong with being oh
shut up
every two every time every time whatever
all right I'm gonna get more of aid
skill because that's what I want I want
to not be hit now I'm gonna get more way
down before I spend my blood I'll should
I get combat I'll never get enough for
that does this face the facts I'm never
gonna get enough for that but I might
get enough for this the bullet cascade
Tama ammo go for that next I just need
15,000 more but I don't even know if I'm
gonna get enough for the end of the game
but
we'll do it we'll do what I got to do
honor of combat skill no no way
do I look like I need it actually I just
upgrade my combat skills oh absolutely I
probably do need it I just want the
bullet cascade that sounds really cool
and such and the like as that such as
the like as that stuff stove yeah okay
all right but at least we can save Jojo
Jojo will live even if Sebastian if
Lilly doesn't make it out of here alive
I will be knowing that Jojo survived cuz
Franco I already mourned well god that's
horrible that's horrible I should shut
up Oh was there anybody surprised Bryce
cries it's me I'm not going am I going
the right way
oh you're not gonna get to me oh all
right well before I do that because that
seems final let me check around this
elevator thing soup casket yeah where's
my cascading soup that's what I'm really
in about well I'm really on for it oh
that looks problematic huh alright well
that's nice
all the architecture in here alright I'm
on the way now I love a soup cascade I
know it's terrible I know but why are
you all laughing at it then
so who's the terrible person then it's
terrible alright hang on woof these
stairs are really getting to me man if
any was actually watching me in stem
they're like what is he doing it keeps
running and really erratic patterns he
could just turn his head and look but it
just keeps running everywhere back and
forth throughout this whole place
something wrong with that guy maybe
stems affecting him more negatively than
we originally
anticipated now why does he keep kicking
up indoors isn't she always every time
he kicks up in the door but then
sometimes he doesn't sometimes he takes
it real slow oh that's problem hmm
all right well okay
[Music]
I don't think so
I don't think you like these do old
there's another guy all right well good
this I'm out I'm full of bottle good
thing I got my sneaks no
which way you going you gonna turn
around oh alright I can deal with that
Oh bear hug would you like a coffee
oh why did I pull that Oh what did that
book that out
sorry just got too excited okay so we
got this guy
oh oh he caught me souping wait
let's see how you deal with this soup
man guy you played your all you ruined
me
no he ruined to me oh you ruined me all
right how about smoke fan yeah I bet you
won't like none of this where did I go
Oh weird huh
weird weird let me soup you please let
me soup you please I just a little soup
a little soup please I saw there it is
[Applause]
party
oh that don't sound good oh no I went
the wrong way I thought whoa dodge sweet
Doge dumbest Oh weird whoa what happened
where's the smoke all the smoke should
be there there was no smoke oh that was
a bomb
I didn't mean oh okay this is a problem
yeah hey excuse me I'm being Oh God
it's Thor's thing all right
you'll never know where I come from so
weird why can't I ambush you
what that's not well why why why why
what what am i doing nails I pick up
nails wife oh geez I'm an idiot okay you
know what I got this it may not look
like I got this but trust me when I say
[Music]
whoa what the hell happened there
ah and wait wait for it here comes the
soup soups coming awful soups not on not
on alright fine you know what
Oh like you guys you guys you guys make
fun of my soup skills when in reality my
swole bear hug time barely boy what the
hell whoa thanks for taking that blow
for me Jesus
okay those guys get soup from now on
Wow okay well that's unfair oh this
ain't good okay
Esmeraude I was getting better at the
game
yeah it didn't work some telling me I
don't think the spicy soup is gonna be
palatable for them and let me try this
again please one more chance of
redemption okay one down you always got
to soup these guys because if you don't
soup them oh I think someone spotted me
I'm not hard Sanchar but I'm pretty sure
Oh yep that sounds like someone's right
behind me huh oh boy without a problem
that's from let me shift it please oh
boy okay you didn't see nothing because
you'll never see nothing again because
of this whoo come here
come closer and closer and closer please
let me soup you please let I'm
approaching I'm souping I'm souping I've
got okay hey you know what
I ain't gonna work something tells me
stealth ain't gonna solve my problems
okay everybody hold on
bye hold on everybody everybody I know
y'all giggling I know y'all giggling and
rubbing your heads in frustration and
the such ass but what about a bottle do
you ever think about that pup miss but
miss up miss up got him you ever think
about that see my strategy you see him
whoa that's not good there's to be a lot
problems going on here everyone seems to
be so so caught up in life Oh friend
your hands
no aim paint shoot fire that guy thing
all right what the hell
now climb down oh please Oh No Oh No
one who can't get more nails out of this
black what what am i why I was quick
about this last time
now I'm slow okay well yeah that's
problem okay
see what a shock ball does this guy
where to go go where to go
or the hell did he just go
no come on oh yeah right there
was that gonna do can I shoot yeah oh
yes I can
oh that's the perfect soup skill okay
perfect okay shock bolt seems to be
effective for soup in please let me do
it again repeat my soup performance to
performance model that's bro all right
well god it's so finicky with the soup I
guess the ignore me
again
Hey
yeah let me see if I can soup this guy
maybe if a good old-fashioned soul
a good old-fashioned all-white he's got
done he's got super senses
all right try another shock bolt
down this hole
[Music]
nope apparently not
nope no such luck okay I'm just gonna
try to get away now finish them off with
good old-fashioned bullets
what a gun as bullets what gun none of
them okay so I'm completely out of
handgun bullets I've got four and here
do this
weird huh how about that
and I please please please I was more
god damn it okay [ __ ] I can't rely on
that even though I keep trying
god damn what a piece of [ __ ] what a
pizza [ __ ]
oh god this guy don't go down all right
how about another I'm gonna explode
[Music]
I
brighten your gullet I see that oh whoa
that's not what I meant to it but I hit
it I'm gonna be super fast oh oh oh come
on fire Jesus oh boy oh boy oh boy
let me try another bullet piggy
he's speeding god damn it okay no no no
no no no no oh god me too really okay
well oh [ __ ] oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
ah this is this is panic inducing what
if I got whatever guy I know I got a few
more shotgun nope not that one oh this
is got two two shots in it so good use
this one but only if it really stops him
otherwise I'm gonna just be found okay
wait hang on I got change this is what
I'm going for
okay completely out of ammo on that one
all I've got left is Boone's
are you okay I think okay what do I have
nothing although I don't think those are
actually gonna do any damage to them
what the hell just bounce right off of
them really good god okay can I please
just ambush him would be a lovely lovely
adventure okay that's not gonna work
floaties there there finally Jesus
Jason's geminate Christmas oh yeah if I
didn't know that I wouldn't just kill
them here I didn't need to kill off I
didn't need to kill those other two oh
my god
yeah what happened what happened to me
where did I go okay let me are you don't
don't turn on [ __ ] off brake ring around
the Rosie
all right Wow okay
man I wish I had bullets wish I had
bullets I got all these assault rifle
sacs but no bullets oh yeah yeah okay
I'm gonna collect everything and then
I'm gonna make my way down wolf
oh alright is there anything else here
that I need doubt it okay I can't get
through there that's where I need to go
yeah if I don't know that hi
legitimately I would have just uh I
would have yeah I would've just wait
until I come in here and kill them start
killing them out there and wasting all
my ammo on the ones that I didn't need
to kill oh yeah yeah yeah I see okay
there's something still in there
whoa instead of demagogue oh he's stuck
in the wall
ah he is stuck in the wall okay good to
know
all right got some foon's let me see if
I can field craft anything probably more
harpoon bolts
okay takes two pipes to do that in the
wild oh god they're killing me uh no I'm
gonna hold off I still got some stuff
right I'm not gonna do I have to kill
that Demma dog it's stuck in the wall
Oh Oh there was a whole other area here
oh this thing ah I get it oh it's all a
big circle well that would have been
good to know all right
easy as pie I didn't even have to kill
them all
why why why why would you do that to me
hire whoever submissions face
Sebastian's face reflects how I feel
right now
very grumpy okay any other ammo ooh
sound here and there was all sorts of
stuff oh that's weird oh well alright
then no I don't want the thing on the
ground I want this
[Music]
are they dying they'll need some hot
spicy soup oh you did not you had plenty
of spicy soup read there for you okay
sure hope no one locks me in here and
burns that'd be bad
oh boy here I go on the slow search
through this yeah timeliness not of the
essence okay why was this here
ah oh it opened okay I thought that was
gonna be a closed and kind of kill me
kind of thing instead it was the
opposite
yeah take the longest possible soup
delivery oh no wow you missed me yeah
[ __ ]
alright I don't want to waste anything
on you I have so little of everything
ouch
he's right there
maybe he's gonna turn around I don't
know if he's gonna come all the way up
here
yeah he's probably gonna turn around
maybe that's to be killed oh no no no no
no no no
oh my god this guy this everyone's been
just the biggest dick today can you
believe it I can hardly believe it all
right
[Music]
okay everybody it's wolf stress pool but
we made it through I think we made it
through okay we've got two more [ __ ]
over there that's not what I wanted all
right well I get that I guess I got the
snub nose yeah yeah okay we got two more
[ __ ] over here maybe they can give
us some more supplies so long as I can
soup them right let's bottle okay okay
come on yeah and I am gonna finish this
today I am gonna finish this it'll be a
bit longer
stream probably another hour or so I
didn't know but I want to finish this I
want to finish this because I'm super
into it as frustrated as I am I'm super
into it
no-no-no
yeah
I'm trying to get this guy whoever could
no don't flame on
don't flame on don't flame on please
don't claim on template guys okay yes
yes yes yes no get out of there whoa ah
no no no no no no no fries no idea where
I hope he knows he knows he knows you
know I'm all go all the long way around
Oh
mysterious huh
I almost got enough for the consecutive
bullet cascade kind of thing
where you going buddy are you going yes
yes yes yes yes yes
in your mouth Oh what did I get on me
gross oh no no no what do you see what
do you think you see I don't think you
see what you think you see flame off
flame off flame off flame off flame off
please flip up oh right
Oh the wrong time at the exact opposite
time that you should have flamed off
okay
stay flame off no you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you piece of ass how can you be
dick how can you be such dick all right
[ __ ] douche your dose you freakin
douche
yeah
flame off right this way
just super super okay it counts it
counts counts counts is soup counts soup
dripping good alright alright here we go
good god that's that really shouldn't
have taken that long that really
shouldn't have taken that long
there's no way oh there's 17 chapters oh
okay alright then it's not even real
Oh gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha
if you are I'm gonna help an [ __ ]
like you take over [ __ ] like them
you're even crazier than luck all right
yeah boy
okay let me just stop if that's the case
then I'm gonna get through this
find a save point I'll probably get e
Audi but I don't know we'll see how it
goes
goddamn okay huh
my heart's going like a million miles an
hour just because of that last point was
it wasn't because it was scary or
anything but it was so stressful like
it's so stressful like I know what I'm
doing at the time and yet even thusly I
gotta just wham bam thank you ma'am
well please tell me there's a mirror in
here somewhere
ooh a note okay when I have become the
core oh and built this new world in my
image reality will soon follow
Moebius have already created footholds
in all aspects of society and they were
foolish enough to implant themselves
with ticking time bombs inside their
minds they consider themselves wolves in
the rest sheep but I am the herder
waiting to call the wolves when they're
not looking
once Union Falls to me Mobius his days
are numbered
okay all right then you think they're
gonna allow that why should why would
you write that down why'd you write all
that down that's the biggest question
that I got right here all right okay so
given the new knowledge that I have
about the length of this game which is
great cuz I love this game I'm having a
tough time but I'm not failing that's
the thing it's just taking me a little
bit longer so thank you everybody so
much for watching remember to pay
respects for Hoffman is dearly departed
and I really appreciate you guys being
here I will get through this maybe not
in the next episode but possibly
depending I will be streaming tomorrow
at 8 a.m. and there will be a new video
coming out today at noon and thanks
again for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye